[Música]
en República Dominicana comenzó la
versión número 28 de la Cumbre
iberoamericana un espacio de
acercamiento para tratar temas como el
cambio climático migración e integración
hace minutos terminó la reunión de
cancilleres las conclusiones del
encuentro en unos minutos las tendremos
en reporte desde la capital dominicana
Estados Unidos y Canadá anunciaron un
nuevo acuerdo que busca reducir los
índices de migración irregular de
personas solicitantes de asilo que
cruzan la frontera común por su parte
Canadá ampliará en 15.000 los cupos para
migrantes de América Latina Tenemos
reporte desde la ciudad de Washington
y Naciones Unidas presentó evidencia de
al menos 40 ejecuciones de prisioneros
de guerra desde que comenzó la invasión
rusa a Ucrania el documento indica que
los asesinatos han sido cometidos tanto
por ucranianos como por rusos 11 de
estas muertes han sido perpetradas por
mercenarios del grupo ruso Wagner
Muy buenas tardes Bienvenidos a las
noticias de France 24 soy Santiago López
González Gracias por estar con nosotros
a esta hora comenzó en República
Dominicana La Cumbre iberoamericana su
versión número 28 una Cumbre que reúne a
los líderes y a presidentes y jefes de
estado representantes gubernamentales
también de las naciones de América
Latina así como de España Portugal y el
principado de andorra en donde son
abordados temas bilaterales como el
medio ambiente materia comercial y ya
hay una de las primeras conclusiones
tras el encuentro de los cancilleres de
los países que están allí reunidos para
ampliar este tema Vamos hasta Santo
Domingo Allí se encuentra nuestra
enviada especial Rosa Pérez masdeu Muy
buenas tardes Rosa y bueno finalizó esta
primera reunión de cancilleres que
dijeron a qué conclusiones llegaron
Buenas tardes Santiago Pues a los
cancilleres aquí reunidos finalmente
están preparando han preparado
analistado ya el documento la
declaración de Santo Domingo que
firmarán mañana jefes de gobierno y los
jefes de Estados presentes aquí en
República Dominicana para esta Cumbre
iberoamericana y lo que ya se ha
constatado es que se firmará la carta
iberoamericana por los derechos
digitales también la carta
medioambiental iberoamericana así como
un plan de ruta crítico para atajar la
situación de inseguridad alimentaria que
afecta a la región Y es que recordemos
que según el último informe de la FAO el
40% más del 40% de hecho de la población
a latinoamericana vive bajo situación de
inseguridad moderada o leve inseguridad
alimentaria pero sin embargo se cae uno
de los Pilares de esta Cumbre que era la
petición de una nueva arquitectura
financiera para que los países de la
región pudieran acceder más fácilmente
préstamos y acreditos internacionales
otra de las cuestiones que no está
explícitamente en este documento final
según hemos podido comprobar gracias a
un borrador al que hemos atendido acceso
Es que tampoco hay una mención
finalmente a la guerra en Ucrania Aunque
Sí una compromiso para trabajar para la
paz total digamos para la paz completa y
digamos evitar los efectos adversos de
Las Guerras por otro lado rápidamente
también una cuestión que nos ha
confirmado la cancillería de Venezuela
que ha sido su petición y es el rechazo
un ánimo a la aplicación de medidas
coercitivas unilaterales violatorias del
derecho internacional que impidan el
desarrollo de los estados Rosa Quiero
preguntarle por un hecho al margen de
esta Cumbre justo enfrente del centro de
convenciones donde tenía lugar este
encuentro una pequeña manifestación de
ciudadanos dominicanos que fue disipada
por la policía que reclamaba no que
querían dar a conocer ante los
asistentes
pues Santiago De hecho estas escenas de
personas lo que querían era aprovechar
que la atención de la comunidad
internacional o al menos de la comunidad
iberoamericana está centrada aquí en
Santo Domingo para mostrar expresar su
descontento con a las políticas del
presidente Luis abinader pero también
por las consecuencias que tiene en
términos de aumento del costo de vida de
los productos básicos de escasez de
medicamentos o también de la política
represiva contra los que llaman sus
hermanos haitianos espero como bien lo
decías está estos manifestantes
denunciaban el acoso de la fuerza
pública Y es que finalmente Así ha sido
de hecho la Policía Militar nos ha
apartado de esta congregación para
dispersar enseguida a los manifestantes
con gases lacrimógenos Rosa pues muchas
gracias por este completísimo reporte
desde Santo Domingo en la República
Dominicana con los detalles de esta
primera conclusión de la reunión de
cancilleres toda la información de esta
cumbre iberoamericana en su versión
número 28 la pueden tener aquí en a lo
largo de este fin de semana nos vamos
ahora hasta la ciudad de hora la capital
de Canadá y el presidente de Estados
Unidos Joe biden y el Primer Ministro de
ese país Justine
a cada país devolver a los solicitantes
de asilo que hayan cruzado la frontera
norte Sin autorización la medida hace
parte de ese esfuerzo de los gobiernos
sobre todo el gobierno de Estados Unidos
para disuadir a los solicitantes de
asilo para entrar al país sin
autorización para entender Más del
alcance de esta medida conectamos o
recibimos el reporte de Cristóbal
Vázquez corresponsal de France 24 en la
ciudad de Washington que nos da más
información
en su primera visita de estado a Canadá
Joey del se reunió con Justin anunciaron
un nuevo acuerdo migratorio que permite
ambos países rechazar a los solicitantes
de asilo no autorizados el acuerdo es
una actualización de un acuerdo ya
conocido y firmado antes en el 2004 que
se conoce como tercer país seguro y que
exigía los migrantes pedir asilo en un
tercer país precisamente antes de llegar
a un puerto de entrada oficial ya sea en
Estados Unidos o Canadá sin embargo este
nuevo este antiguo acuerdo no aplicaba
para las personas que cruzaban la
frontera hacia el norte sin permiso o
entraban de forma no autorizada y
terminaban aplicando al asilo ya sea
desde Canadá o Estados Unidos así
entonces Canadá podrá enviar a los
solicitantes de asilo no autorizados de
regreso a Estados Unidos si son
detenidos dentro de los 14 días
posteriores a cruzar la frontera y
Estados Unidos podrá hacer lo mismo con
los solicitantes de asilo no autorizados
como parte del acuerdo Canadá también
anunció que acogerá a 15 migrantes que
pidan asilo desde sus países a través de
una aplicación Móvil habilitada por este
país cabe Resaltar que las detenciones
de migrantes que tratan de entrar a
Estados Unidos desde Canadá han
aumentado significativamente así como
los migrantes que tratan de llegar a
Canadá desde Estados Unidos pasamos
Ahora hasta México en donde el
presidente Andrés Manuel López Obrador
rechazó los comentarios hechos por el
secretario de estado de Estados Unidos
Anthony blinquen recordemos que el
funcionario afirmó que el gobierno
mexicano había perdido control de parte
del país haciendo referencia a la fuerte
presencia de los carteles ligados al
narcotráfico el mandatario mexicano
discrepó Indicó que la afirmación era
falsa que no existía ningún lugar del
territorio nacional en donde no haya
presencia de la autoridad Aunque aceptó
que algunos de los carteles han
infiltrado personas en la agencia
regulatoria de medicamentos del país
para que apoyen la importación de
precursores químicos de fentanilo
procedentes de China que había regiones
de México dominadas por el narco eso es
falso
No es cierto el señor
que está en su papel
[Música]
porque él representa
los intereses
de las empresas estadounidenses o sea es
su
trabajo más noticias la misión de
observación de derechos humanos de la
ONU para Ucrania ya conocer un informe
en el que documenta los efectos de la
guerra en la población ucraniana el
organismo asegura que las cifras son
alarmantes en términos de ejecuciones
sumarias por ambos bandos involucrados
en este conflicto además reportó
múltiples casos de desapariciones
forzadas torturas y violencia sexual
Manuel acá no tiene los detalles en el
siguiente informe
la situación humanitaria Es crítica en
Ucrania la oficina de monitoreo de
derechos humanos de Naciones Unidas para
el país europeo desveló en un informe
parte de los efectos en la población por
la invasión rusa los civiles asesinados
se cuentan por miles
la guerra ha producido un costo humano
horrendo hasta esta semana hemos
documentado más de 8.000 civiles que han
muerto y casi 14.000 que han resultado
heridos
más del 90% fueron causados por misiles
armas o Minas explosivas y restos
explosivos de guerra
desde el 24 de febrero del año pasado la
organización ha documentado 621 casos de
desapariciones forzadas y detenciones
arbitrarias de civiles por parte de las
fuerzas armadas rusas y también reportó
133 casos de violencia sexual
relacionados con el conflicto otras de
las modalidades que preocupan a la ONU
son los traslados irregulares que
incluyen niños no acompañados desde
regiones ucranianas mientras estaban
bajo control ruso
También estamos profundamente
preocupados por la ejecución sumaria de
15 prisioneros de guerra ucranianos Poco
después de ser capturados por las
fuerzas armadas rusas los contratistas
militares y de seguridad del grupo
Wagner perpetraron 11 de estas
ejecuciones
pero aseguró que Ucrania tampoco ha
estado exenta de esas prácticas y ha
documentado la ejecución sumaria de 25
prisioneros de guerra rusos
la ONU también delató casos de tortura
por parte de las fuerzas rusas más del
84% de los soldados detenidos
entrevistados por la misión sufrió tales
malos tratos y el Rey Carlos III del
Reino Unido canceló su viaje de estado a
Francia debido a la ola de protestas y
manifestaciones todo esto por la
adopción de la Reforma al sistema
francés de pensiones el presidente de
ese país Emanuel Mako que se niega a dar
marcha atrás con su proyecto de ley tuvo
que admitir que el clima político actual
de la nación no es adecuado para una
visita de estado y menos una visita real
Gabriel colchón nos cuenta más en el
siguiente informe
un viaje real cancelado por el clima de
tensión en Francia el presidente
confirmó que la visita del Rey Carlos
III será aplazada debido al aula de
manifestaciones que entró en su noveno
día el jueves y que dio lugar a hechos
de violencia en varias ciudades del país
los sindicatos anunciaron una nueva
jornada de movilización el martes y la
visita del Rey estaba prevista del lunes
al miércoles creo que no estaríamos
serios y careceríamos de sentido común
si propusiéramos a Su Majestad el rey y
a la reina consorte que vinieran a
visitarnos en medio de las
manifestaciones
el domingo por tres días en una
importante visita de estado pero el país
se ha visto afectado por las huelgas y
protestas masivas tras la adopción del
proyecto de ley que breve subir la edad
legal de jubilación de 62 a 64 años
hace bien en no venir ahora hay
protestas y huelgas por todas partes si
es normal ya que París es una ciudad con
verdaderos sí es una ciudad turística
pero no es solo eso hay gente que vive
aquí y que tienen necesidades
más de un millón de personas
participaron en las protestas del jueves
según el gobierno y tres coma cinco
millones según los sindicatos los
manifestantes y las organizaciones
sociales culpan al gobierno por no
prestar atención a la creciente
indignación ciudadana también lo acusan
de haber adoptado la reforma gracias al
uso de poderes especiales que forzaron
la aprobación del proyecto sin el voto
de la asamblea nacional
la invasión de Estados Unidos a Irak
abrió espacio para que la República
islámica de Irán el principal enemigo de
Estados Unidos en Oriente medio y contra
quien Sadam hussein peleó una larga
guerra en los años 80 que dará con el
camino abierto para ganar influencia en
el nuevo escenario político del país su
influencia causa rechazo entre los más
jóvenes que desde hace varios años
también rechazan cualquier tipo de
influencia extranjera nuestra mirada
especial a Irak Catalina Gómez Ángel nos
cuenta más en el siguiente reporte
se ha dicho mucho de Quiénes son los
ganadores después de la invasión
norteamericana 2013 es que realmente lo
subo porque las pérdidas humanas y la
violencia que se ha creado en Irak es
inmensamente grande en estos últimos 20
años obviamente muchos hablan que los
ganadores fueron los kurdos que ganaron
estabilidad después de esa persecución
que tuvieron Durante los años de Samsung
Sin que los fue atacando y asesinando en
algunas masacres muchas veces con
ataques de armas químicas en su momento
pero también los chiítas que fueron los
que retomaron el poder no solamente
político del país sino que pudieron
volver a realmente a practicar su fe
especialmente en lugares como en kerbala
pero también se habla de la Victoria
iraní Irán es un país de mayoría Chita
como es la mayoría de edad con una gran
relación con Irak especialmente en estos
de peregrinaje y ha sido un tenido gran
influencia política durante estos 20
años en los muchos de los grupos
políticos que están en el parlamento y
que lideran el país hoy son prohiranías
tienen gran influencia pero es
interesante ver también Cómo opera la
juventud ir aquí actualmente en esas
grandes protestas que fueron en el país
en el 2019 el eslogan eran no Estados
Unidos no Irán para ellos esa violencia
sectaria que surgió después de la
invasión no existe ellos no fueron
testigos eran muy pequeños y ellos
tratan de desmarcarse tanto de un país
como otro Y tratar de ganar la
independencia de Irak sin embargo esto a
nivel político es muchísimo más
complicado como decía anteriormente la
influencia iraní especialmente en la
política y en la economía y en lugares
como estos es inmensamente grande
esto en las noticias de France 24 más
información en France 24.com y también
en las redes sociales siga con nosotros
buenas tardes
[Música]